Well now that we've got the exercise part out of
the way let's return to the details of property three and
see what it means to faithfully represent that have the refinement
faithfully represent the specification. In fact we have to check three things.
There's three criteria that we have to look at. First of all,
is the refinement adequate? That is, is our refinement rich enough to represent
all of the abstract situations? Second, is the refinement total? That is,
are we sure that the cron, concrete level can't get into some state that
doesn't correspond to a possible abstract state? And the third criterion is,
does the refinement model the abstract level. That is, is each
abstract operation correctly implemented by a concrete one? We'll look at all
three of these criteria separately, after we introduce a little more notation.